[Applause]
mel gibson is making passion of the
christ too
how the littlest part
yeah but how he comes back
so it's going to be just a fictional
story like walking on the water
wait that was before that was all before
okay maybe he's a prequel
maybe he's a prequel it can't be two if
it's a prequel
well he's doing it like star wars maybe
it's like all that order and [ __ ]
yeah maybe it's passion of the christ
one but it's getting released
second yeah it's a prequel hold on one
second
come in the passion of christ
resurrection no
he comes back i mean what did he do
after coming back
he just came back he said what up and
then he dip now he went to hell for a
minute and like had to like atone for
some sins and he came back up and like
kicked it with the boys for a little
why he had to atone for sins that's
jesus yeah that's the whole point bro
he did everybody loved the world he was
like yeah go
do that [ __ ] for them oh he you know he
fixed them he went to hell
yeah and then he came back up and he had
to go kick it with thomas doubting
thomas who was like yo you didn't really
you're not really jesus and he had to
put his
hands through the holes what do you mean
oh because he didn't believe it yeah i
was doubting thomas he's like you're not
really jealous that sounds kind of fire
to be honest he came back he did all
that [ __ ] probably saved some people and
then he went up to heaven
now that sounds kind of fire be honest
so it could be a cool season yeah this
is
way better than the first part where he
just got his ass
busted for mag long
and just straight disrespected like he
was the son of god yeah
she was like why would they even make
the first one some but his dad sent them
to hell
yo dads be rough
roy jones jr's dad was tough on him roy
jones was damn near jesus in the ring
bro that's proof that jesus was black
keep going because white dads y'all
don't punish each other
that's true that's true yo hold on
no they don't time out yeah yeah it
depends
it depends there's some tough aspects
they definitely are yeah
you're talking about like hipster like
or like hippie soft like
new like new york liberal dads but then
like down south football coach dads who
think that they're
easy on their kids yeah exactly come on
bro
i don't know them country whites how was
your day
my dad was soft as [ __ ] he was mad he's
a new york liberal bro
he's soft super soft on us
i think i was scared once on my dad
really one time that was the only time
what happened what'd you do
i don't remember really he was just
walking to my room loud
that's the scary [ __ ] i knew i did
something [ __ ] up and he was five full
fuming on the way dog and he was
not gonna be good when he got there
what'd he do i don't know
i think i called i don't i never called
him on his bluff but i never what was he
going to do is that he was going to beat
me up
and this was back in the day when you
could call the police on your parents
there was like a hotline
like that yeah there was a hotline for
like
crazy for a minute there was like a
rumor going around that like
kids had done it like everybody had a
friend who had a friend like it was like
working for the cdc but back in the day
it was like calling up your parents beat
you up hotline
and uh and uh i knew the number
and i was ready you would know the
numbers i was
i had that [ __ ] down like it was a
contra code up down up down left right a
b
a b a b select start it was go i was
putting them all in jail
i was putting them all in jails hey yo
my dad beats my as you go to [ __ ]
prison
and uh he didn't even get punished and
you had the number on cube that's
probably why
i was like right dude i'll use the
[ __ ] nighttime minutes
you won't but then you realize you
really got no leverage
and he didn't beat my ass never i never
really got my ass back maybe because you
checked him because you knew the [ __ ]
contra cubs
i think i might have broke your mom
didn't it my mom might have tried to
beat my ass she was a little more rough
on me
she beat my ass emotionally
she beat my ass emotionally by like just
not loving me for the first 20 years of
my life mind tricks
mind tricks that's effective yeah that's
effective
my mom's just like a cold ass scottish
woman like what does that mean
like she's loving and [ __ ] but she's
also cold as [ __ ] but how does she
trick you like i need to know the no no
you don't need to learn
then you're gonna make a comedian
my mom was very sweet but we also drove
her crazy like
any kid though yeah nah come on i was
a wild ass boy i got my andrew we're not
talking about kids he's talking about
andrew he was snitching on his parents
at six years old [ __ ] calling him
i would snitch on my parents but my mom
was also sweet as [ __ ] like she would
like
hide out on babysitters to make sure
they were babysitting right
why not when you act like uh i never
told you this wait
she was i never told you this she was
spying on me i think you
once started yeah
my mom like she would hire a babysitter
and this is when i was mad young and
then
she would hide out in the bushes in the
park and
just wait and see if the babysitter was
doing [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
i mean that's because they didn't have
videos or cameras back then exactly
and then she found a babysitter who was
doing [ __ ] [ __ ] with me
the babysitter would just leave me in a
swing oh wait for an hour yo
well she didn't push me nothing you know
what's [ __ ] up about this
it wasn't even cell phones back then she
was just sitting there doing nothing too
i was like yo you could have had
something fun to do push me [ __ ]
not playing angry birds or nothing right
literally i get if you have a phone if
you like this and not pay attention fine
but you were sitting there bored as [ __ ]
as me
look at each other like yo you wanna
play or no you gonna play
i don't have a pump yet i need a pump
i pump this wig we need you i did not
see that flip your hell's [ __ ] up your
mom just let you sit there the whole
hour that's all so [ __ ]
up my mom told me the story oh she's
like she goes she goes
and i and i watched her for an hour
you're just sitting there you're almost
crying the whole time
and i was like yo that's [ __ ] up but
why the [ __ ] did you not step
in yo it's just your mom you with some
random chicks stared at each other all
three of us bored out of our goddamn
minds wasted a whole hour
mom didn't have a phone either she
wasn't playing i know
tap on the shoulder after half well you
thought someone's gonna change you
though 45 minutes kicking and she's not
pushing me
that's hilarious it's unbelievable bro
that's unbelievable
my dad's probably hiding out somewhere
else
i wonder if she got a good babysitter
for our boy
your grandpa's watching your dad whole
line of distrust not my grandpa watching
my mom
like damn look at her behind her i like
to get behind her bush that's just
make sure you're not trying anything on
my wife
wow that was a real stand up bro you had
a scottish standoff
bro so yeah love your kids not a
standoff there's a bunch of people
standing around not loving each other
you go first no you
do it you do it
oh my gosh oh yeah my loving scottish
family we love it's just different
we broke yeah black families is that is
that like now but brad i feel like black
families have so much like love in the
culture like it's uh
no we do but yeah at the same time you
know we get on people's nerves and
everything else like
whoop this [ __ ] yeah my dad's side is
super loving
and i'm glad that that's kind of like
what we passed passed down there are
tons of things i got from my mom's side
like
just like wittiness and busting balls
that's all from
yeah scots are nice of that they are yo
the women
are crazier than the dudes i mean 100
the men in the family were like tough
like union
working you know working class dudes
they're not keeping up with these girls
bro
and now you just knew aunt annie nobody
could keep up
on edith nobody could keep up aunt annie
was this big like brooding
you know r.i.p but she kind of looked
like groot a little bit oh my gosh
rip you know what i'm saying but like
but she
but she would walk in a room and then
just slice everybody up bro
she would come every summer and just
slice ever you walk in a room
she finds something and i was like
that's where i learned it i really do
i was like i had to survive i was
survival mode bro
yeah yeah yeah interesting
that's why black people that's why black
ducks do the dozens right it's like you
need to have somebody that you bust
balls with if you're gonna learn it you
tell people that never like had
that type of relationship they just
don't know how to do it yeah you know
what i mean i'm trying to think of like
certain people that like don't like
they get upset when you make fun of them
yeah they kind of show up or get
defensive or something
yeah well they can't just laugh at
themselves yeah like i'm trying to find
who
i don't know woke white women yeah
and and also like it can come from like
a baby
sometimes a lot of times it happens with
women as there's like an overprotection
i understand that too like
you have this daughter that you love so
much right you don't want anything bad
to happen to her ever
right she's your little baby or whatever
it is but in a way you kind of protect
her and then stop her from developing
these skills which is the ability to
protect herself
you're not always going to be there
protecting your daughter mm-hmm you know
and some of you
got to get her feelings hurt a little
bit she hates seeing her get her
feelings hurt her crying they'll
probably
[ __ ] crush you yeah but it's
important for her to do that and almost
better she gets her feelings hurt at
home from the people she loves the most
yeah because nobody's going to be able
to [ __ ] with her the way that you can
i feel like just spoiled brats though it
is like
because i had older siblings they you
have all their brothers hey
i have older brother and sister i think
the most important thing at least for me
like dating but like
the most important thing that a girl can
have is an older brother
because it's because she has one dude
and his friends she has men that she has
to if she wants to hang out with them
win over without using sex
it's very easy when you're an attractive
girl right to like win over and like get
guys to pay attention
you know what i mean like if if you want
a guy to pay attention to you you could
say the dumbest story in the world and
they're just going to sit there and they
go
oh that's fascinating but your brother's
friends
it's not like that be funnier we're
making fun of you yeah
pretty much right so then you learn oh
[ __ ] i gotta be funny i gotta be more
economical with these stories
this but i have like cousins like boy
cousins all the other stuff you're a
close family
that's like like you you always tell me
all of your cousins are like extended
brother sisters yeah we didn't even know
what cousins were growing up
that's just brother sisters yeah
and it'd be like third cousins and i'm
like that's my brother and then
americans are like what the [ __ ] are you
talking how are you guys relating i'd be
like i'll be honest i don't know
but i know that's my brother that's what
look but then you got this big ass
family everybody just shits on each
other and that's how you get tough i
think
yeah so it's completely reasonable it's
completely okay it's like
i think white people are very specific
and it's not even trying to be racist
you're just very specific about how
you're related to each other
no no i mean like in terms of how you
rip on each other oh you go
because it's so funny because when i
hear about like the stand-up scene which
is blowing up in india
yeah but whenever i hear about it from
like india comics they say that there's
like a political correctness
there's a political correctness but you
can [ __ ] on each other as individuals
mercilessly okay which is weird it's
like identity [ __ ] like don't [ __ ] on my
political
culture or i guess my religion probably
because there's so much conflict
built into the history religious
religion-wise yeah but you won't make
fun of a fat person or whatever i don't
really see like
triggered [ __ ] like that maybe like the
uber liberals in like mumbai which is
like their new york
you know what i mean they'll but like
the average person you're making fun of
how they look they'll go [ __ ]
okay good yeah cause i was thinking it
was always confusing me you always say
how like ruthless your uncle was to you
and [ __ ]
vicious dog but and then when i hear
that these people out there saying like
yeah the comedy's really pc i mean
what do you mean i thought culturally
you guys just go at it culturally we go
at it but weirdly and i think again it's
just a lot of conflict built into the
region
like religion wise and so there's high
stakes with everything that said because
you're like
on the verge of war if you're talking
about politics yeah and that's where we
get sensitive but if you don't make fun
of a fat person i've never seen that
become a thing